at ABC it was like you know this a
mainstream and this isn't just correct
and then there are you wackos it wasn't
that difficult for me to give him the
ABC career it was a pay cut but I hated
them it was time to go home
money isn't everything and liberty is
and I like you wanted to vote my life
spreading these ideas so the the
question becomes how do we get this
stuff out and how people just in - it's
just not intuitive to people it wasn't
intuitive to me I only I'm stupider than
most of you or less innately wise about
this stuff and then I had to be a
regulator a consumer reporter until I
was whacked in the face by a reality and
I saw it didn't work and then I took the
trouble to study and find a reason and
so forth - some of you it just comes
instinctively and so as this weekend has
gone by I'm thinking about look how much
we've gained I mean are we winning or
losing in many ways it's great we seem
to be winning Ron Paul it's a good
example he is doing twice as well as he
did in the national in the last
presidential race that he ran and that's
great
okay that's exciting that's Jesse he
sends you these little emails good
second place in Nevada is is great and
Nick and Matt on the same day they were
presenting here they're in The Wall
Street Journal on the end column about
you know other interesting things we
want a quote and they're quoting Reason
magazine and that's great and as they
talked about there are more independence
now and Matt's going and debating at AEI
and Nick's debating Ann Coulter five
years ago ten years ago we just weren't
that wouldn't happen libertarians would
not have been on that radar screen I
have a show at Fox Andrew Napolitano has
a Daily Show
Luis Fortuno is selected here in Puerto
Rico and really make Scott see all the
fuss in Wisconsin Governor Walker didn't
fire anybody
this guy here fired 30,000 people and
she says he's got to be reelected and
then I'm reading The Times the other day
in New York Times and they're doing a
story on the TSA and the competition
from private private airport security
and I sort of scan it and I see this
name pool
oh is this Bob pool with a quoting Bob
pool go back to the article you have to
search her oh yeah the reason fun
foundation and they don't say that the
whack job Reason Foundation they excite
him just like he's another expert and I
think how hard he's worked from the
beginning and and that he's achieved
normalcy this is a wonderful thing and
and so all that's great and and then I
come here and it's wonderful to be with
all of you and the informal
conversations and then Bob and I have
last night an informal meeting in the
men's room over there where I mentioned
what I just said he tells me yeah Matt
that's a the rare reporter who really
tries to understand and get it right and
I think oh you mean it's not that the
public has moved in this direction and
says this is a rare reporter who tries
to get it right so that's a little less
enthusiastic and then I think of Luis
Fortuno and I've been here for since
Thursday and asking people who I can ask
it's mostly the kids who I play
volleyball with or there's 30 year olds
and they hate him and he I think did the
right things and I did a fox piece on
him that weekend if you want an email
copy just give me your email address and
I'll send it to you it sort of gives a
perspective on what he did but he
talks in terms of he if you watch the
State of the Union Obama's speech was
just socialism was ridiculous but if you
didn't really think about it it sounded
pretty good it appealed to the heart
mitch Daniels speech he said all the
right stuff but it appealed to the head
David that was talking about this at
lunch this the appealing to the heart is
often more popular and Lewis like many
of us he uses phrases like you know when
the guys that when the thugs the Union
thugs at the toll booth were stealing
money he he says we had revenue leakage
and I'm thinking well you know he's the
one who said that it Ronald Reagan did
the right thing the economy recovered
people understood that big landslide
election so we looked for and Beck that
can work and we looked for other
examples we found John Engler Michigan
got elected again Gary Johnson in New
Mexico but he certainly didn't resonate
with the Republican Party Mitch Daniels
I guess though he's not all that popular
but they're the rare exceptions more
often what you understand and what is so
important and has lifted people out of
the poverty out of poverty is just not
intuitive to people and Scott Walker may
get recalled I think of New Zealand
which was down the socialist drain and
they conservatives came in and or
libertarians and saved the country and
then they got thrown out
people don't understand private sector
they don't like it intuitively it seems
selfish Margaret Thatcher saves Britain
gets thrown out Milton Friedman uses
Hong Kong as the example of a country
that went from third world the first
world in just fifty years why cuz they
had economic freedom but what a
wonderful thing so I for a story go to
Hong Kong
and interview people there and they
don't know why they're prosperous they
just talk about what problems there are
and how government should solve them
they don't get what worked Chile as well
josè paneer I created this private
privatize social security system it's
saved in bankruptcy they all have
savings accounts I go there thinking
they'd celebrate that Jose says yeah
they hold up their savings account now
since I have money in the bank well I
couldn't find anybody who did that they
just said I'm I'm you know my Merrill
Lynch is charging me too much in fees
for my private account they complained
and most recently their riots in Chile
the most prosperous country in South
America because some kids go to private
school and they get a better education
and that's unfair equality is more fair
when I pick up the New York Times last
weekend I know if you saw in the weekend
review section there's this beautiful 23
year old girl leading demonstrations of
young people where two hundred thousand
people show up and do imitate Michael
Jackson dances and just wonderful show
business and upgrade a young leader
she's a communist communism is just
intuitive to people Liberty is
counterintuitive it takes brain work so
we have an uphill battle I mean Mary
O'Grady last night said prohibition and
protectionism are popular and people
will curtayne Liberty in the name of
equality it just feels good she said it
with some preset at about South America
I think it's true of North America too
so I want to get this message out so I'm
an ABC I'm getting the message out
sometimes but everyone is a fight it's
like pushing string and they let me do
it because I was reasonably successful
in the ratings but they never liked it
and as the years went on it was just
tougher to get these stories on there
were several I wanted to put on that
they just sit
which one was healthcare I had done an
hour on healthcare Christie went to
Canada where she found the one area
where Canadians get instant care and can
get into the pot of the surgery room in
one day get an MRI right away you know
you can't normally but you have to have
you have to bark or meow because these
are veterinary offices which is still
private but we we had good pieces
together and then came Obamacare and
this was my chance to update it and they
weren't interested oh you're predictable
we don't want to do that and instead
they had a town meeting at the White
House and people at meetings like this
used to say what why don't you go to Fox
you have a friendlier environment and
believe me I wouldn't like that at ABC
Peter Jennings if he saw me in the hall
would go I just was just not it wasn't
fun to be there in many ways but Fox had
a tiny audience compared to ABC when I
first did specials my first one are we
scaring ourselves to death or boys and
girls are different that was
controversial at ABC we got 15 17
million people these are larger than
American Idol numbers today and I would
say well why go to Fox and preach that
the convert converted and far fewer
people but by two years ago we were down
to five million people in 2020 and they
didn't want to air this stuff and the
Fox was up Oh Riley on his reruns now
total gets about five million people a
business channel has far fewer viewers
but with the repeats gets up into the
millions and thanks to some of you I get
12 million people watching these free
market videos via Andrea rich who some
of you know who runs this charity called
stossel in the classroom where we take
the stuff from TV and offer it free to
teachers and enough teachers now get
them that about 12 million kids every
year watch free market video
ABC tried to kill off this project many
times and and I had to say if you want
me you have to allow this and they
charged a lot of money for the video Fox
gives it free so it's cheaper now but
the satisfaction is that the 12 million
is higher than the 20/20 audience these
days so so that's satisfying but you
know then how do we get get these ideas
out so that's what I'm doing Stossel in
the classroom and then I eight years ago
I wrote a last book this one I hope to
keep on the bestseller list so Christie
arranges an arduous three-week tour to
try to get to enough places to get on
the bestseller list at least to get the
ideas to people so if we're hitting your
town in April I'm going to Washington DC
atlanta
Austin Troy Alabama Tallahassee the
villages in Florida Tampa Albuquerque
Tucson Phoenix Los Angeles Napa Palo
Alto Denver Salt Lake City Logan Utah
sand San Jose
Orange County San Francisco that's a
recent event Chicago Indianapolis
Minneapolis st. Paul and Philadelphia so
if you want to organize some group to
come here the presentation there and
help try to get this book on the list
please do and the subtitle is this is
why government fails but individuals
succeed make sense to you but remember
every time there's a crisis people say
there ought to be a law it's not
intuitive to believe that after 9/11
everybody was scared Tom Daschle said I
mean Bob Poole has talked about the
insanity of the TSA and there's a Wall
Street Journal article about them the
day and how they're spending much more
than the private screeners did before
and and since they were created they've
quadrupled that but Tom Daschle said you
can't professionalize if you don't
federal
and that just makes sense to people it
makes sense to people that if workers
get killed on the job you need
government to come in and create OSHA to
set some standards they say most people
not you I know you're weird most people
would say yeah of course they do and of
course we're a rich country some people
are poor it's just luck that brought you
here and and some people have bad luck
we need the poverty programs Lyndon
Johnson had the right idea health care
it won't work as a market as a New
Yorker story which was by a good writer
normally he said it right but
libertarians want to have medicine so
when you're having a heart attack you're
on the weight of a hospital you're gonna
start calling up and saying who's a good
doctor who's not in which hospital shop
who comes up with these ideas
well Adam Smith for one and you wouldn't
have to decide on the way to the
hospital because reputation speaks brand
names speak word would get out even a
nursing home which were the good places
to go but that's not intuitive to people
education likewise people say all the
parents don't know what the right
curricula should be and they can't judge
education is too important to be left to
the free market that's what teachers
have told me and it's just very hard to
convince them otherwise
so all I can do is try to use my TV
visuals and say yes it's intuitive that
government can run it better but when
government runs things this is what you
get
and remember this was the East German
car this came you know these guys were
rocket sciences these were the smartest
geeks around and an it in the you go
were the best thing they could produce
and you know this would be government
health care and this is our education
system and you know this but this
intuitive thinking there ought to be a
law is why government keeps growing and
here's the graph starts you know the big
increase is really Lyndon Johnson in the
Great Society here it is even out for
population growth but you know as you've
heard many times this is unsustainable
but the Republicans don't want it cut as
Nick and Matt talked about and when they
get the specifics nobody wants to give
up their program and it's so hard to
take them one at a time but that's our
job take them one at a time and to show
why your obvious thinking is wrong let's
take a couple I mentioned OSHA it's
intuitive to say workers get killed on
the job we need OSHA to save them and
look how many have been saved since OSHA
was created the workplace is much safer
than it was in 1971 when OSHA began how
can you argue against this well here's
one way why don't we look at the graph
from before OSHA okay
things get better in a free society I
mean it's hard to sell nobody's out in
front of the cameras saying yay for
marginal improvements that come from
free markets it's just not news word or
think about the war on poverty it is
horrible that some people are poor in
America when I was in college I was
convinced by my professors that Lyndon
Johnson's right with his program and and
they created a welfare and and the
poverty rate dropped from 1965 when when
welfare was created and again you can
say that's great those are lots of
people lifted out of poverty in some way
but then look at the look what happened
since then
oops went back up they taught people to
be dependent but that's people don't
know this you know people think it's up
now because of the evil banks or
something they don't accept the idea
that things might get better on their
own so let's go back before 1965 things
were getting better in their own the
slope of the line was just as steep
maybe it would have continued to drop
had we not created the welfare state and
you know on and on in case after case
that just intuition is a million times
wrong Moz and I were talking at dinner
about radiation people are terrified of
radiation it's just instinctive the
hysteria over the tiny risk from Japan
was absurd Germany I thought they were
sensible they gave up their nuclear
program well in America we have
hysterics over organic food and what's
healthier for you
well thousands of people died hundreds
of thousands get sick from food
poisoning there's a process called food
irradiation they just run it through a
factory it's exposed to cobalt 40
whatever that is it kills the germs they
seal it up strawberries stay fresh for
three weeks meat for just as long the
houses of people would be alive today if
more companies
food some do Omaha Steaks for example
but the the environmental nutballs have
scared states so much that they won't do
it and two states have New Jersey and
Maine had laws against it for a while
the idiots win I mean the purpose of
trying to get this out it's just so many
ways where your intuition is wrong the
best example of the status I would say
would be seatbelts and cars and that's
one area where I think we libertarians
have to say ok well maybe sometimes
governments useful because it you know
mate like Volvo was advertising
seatbelts before it was required but
most people didn't buy and it happened
much faster because government mandated
it and ten thousand lives a year for the
past thirty years since then isn't that
worth it I mean I take the hardcore
position to say that even in that case
maybe not we don't know because I'm sure
thirty thousand lives were saved but
because it became a government mandate
we got one standard now if your auto
company and you think you have a better
seat belt you'd be an idiot to introduce
it to go beyond the standard because if
one person died the trial lawyers would
use that to pounce all over you it's
safer just to go with the standard if
there were competition there might today
be six types of seatbelts all of which
would be safer and more comfortable and
maybe more of us would wear them and
more lives would be saved in the long
run I mean even their best case isn't
the good one but that's just not
intuitive this is school choice week and
we talked something about that earlier
but I mean just wanting it's just so
intuitive we need government to make
sure everyone's educated and Horace Mann
when he created public education in
America inspired at Massachusetts he
said this will end all the crimes of the
penal colony of the penal code sorry
now the schools have all the crimes but
there's this British researcher James
Tooley who goes to the poorest places of
the world in Africa and Asia and finds
it even there because they've copied our
government system even they're horribly
poor parents most of them get private
schooling for their kids pay a dollar to
a day sacrifice because the government
schools the teachers can't get fired
they go to sleep they're horrible
everywhere in the world to protect the
Tigers Tigers are going extinct banned
tiger hunting that's the instinctive
reaction and my book we talked about if
you want to protect Tigers eat Tigers
all right you probably don't want to eat
Tigers but there's no shortage of
Buffalo in America anymore now that some
ranchers had a financial investment just
preserving Buffalo so people could eat
them there are no shortages of chickens
in America because there's a market in
Africa in places where they gave tribes
ownership over their Tigers or rhinos
and they allow hunting they preserve
them because when the poachers come the
tribes kill them or at least beat them
up and send them back home to their
tribe to send a message because now they
have a financial interest in keeping
some elephants or rhinos alive - sucker
white tourists who want to come in and
shoot one a market but the
environmentalists say it's money it's a
market where that's just not the way to
go and you can't convince them and then
lastly and I'll stop on this to take
questions defense like I get to Fox and
I'm uncomfortable with this one because
I've never reported on defense and Ron
Paul has been right about just about
everything though you know it's totally
polishing the fed makes me nervous and
I'm surrounded by people at Fox who have
studied defense and say we need a
stronger military and maybe they know
something I don't the neo-cons have been
right about some things but then I think
about what they want what people want
the military to do to contain China to
chase terrorists to Train foreign
militaries
terrorists to protect the ceilings to
keep oil cheap to stop genocide to
protect European Asian and Middle
Eastern states from aggression the
spread goodwill through humanitarian
missions to respond the natural
disasters secure the internet police the
border and transform failed states like
Afghanistan and Iraq and the democracies
I mean the list is endless and that's
the problem we can't afford that
but if Fox there's just this antipathy
to Ron Paul when you talk about the good
news bad news balance we could say it's
great news he came in second but could
also say it's bad news he came in second
to Mitt Romney and why are we
celebrating that he we should be you
know celebrating only if he takes the
lead because these ideas are better but
it's such a hard sell and I noticed that
at Fox I expected some hostility to my
libertarian ideas and I do these stories
and legalizing sex work drugs
and I expect some pushback and not a
peep and when Sean Hannity and Bill
O'Reilly it criticized me on their shows
about this it's different from ABC
because at ABC it was like you know this
is a mainstream and that's it's just
correct and then there are you wackos
you you on the right wing and you know
you're just silly
but at least at Fox he understands he
has a point of view that we're not just
all objective he has a point of view and
I have a point of view and they will
have that debate and they let me have
that but it's weird about defense
because I'm trying to learn about it by
I listen to Ron Paul then I go to the
conservatives who argue the other side
and I gradually thought gee their
arguments are not very convincing Ron
Paul's are more convincing and often
their argument is to go they don't
really argue the content we had Steve
Forbes in the show I love Steve Forbes
this was during the State of the Union I
know it was during the Republican debate
and Ron Paul made his anti-war
statements and Steve hood go but it's
like it's a sneer it's not an argument
it's the same thing I got from the left
at ABC but John Aguilera talks about the
reaction to Atlas Shrugged is most
vicious from the Liberals and this
surprised him and it surprises me I mean
I thought it would be the Liberals who
would accept our libertarian ideas I
figured how can the Conservatives accept
it and the social conservatives their
religion tells them sex work drug taking
homosexuality just evil I can't they
they will never accept me but but the
liberal some of them are smart they've
seen the failure of the growing
government they will be convinced about
but they're not they are just rigid
hostile well it Fox they welcome
libertarians like me go figure
I don't understand that but I'm not
going to complain about it as long it's
not letting me do that
and I just thank you for what you do
close on one final thought about the
lack of intuitiveness about this hatred
of capitalism that comes up in the
Occupy Wall Street demonstrations we
take it for granted that that we can
take a we can go to a foreign country
good here
San Juan where we don't speak English
and you can stick a piece of plastic in
the wall and cash will come out and you
can give that piece of plastic to
someone who doesn't even speak your
language and he'll rent you a car for a
week and when you get home Visa or
MasterCard will have the accounting
correct to the penny the government
can't even count the votes accurately
but now they want government to run
health care so thank you for fighting
that let liberty win
well thank you very much
John thank you very much that was
terrific as always
now besides you there is our friend
Andrew Napolitano and I'm sure others
who embrace our views even to a very
pure libertarian extent and yet it
strikes me that you alone are out there
trying to educate Napolitano is terrific
but he's not per se educating the way
you are and you're doing it from unique
perspectives and unique ways through the
dialectic and through bringing in the
the as you say the intuitive the
server's and and other cognitive
thinkers like that to explain where our
brains are wrapped our brains are the
way they are and many other respects
what other john stossel's out there are
out there in journalism that can
continue what you're doing
I don't know train some are fine I wish
there were more I would put them on our
show they just are not that many
libertarians who get it I mean thank God
for reason TV where I steal video all
the time to help put these ideas on
right no reason TV works hard at
recruiting people who were able to put
these things onto video
I mean I would say Napolitano does
educate in some ways he has a harder job
he's on five days a week I'm just on one
day a week I do therefore have more time
to try to use video and do things to
make it more accessible to people who
don't already believe and maybe that's
my skill because when I was younger I
didn't get it so I can help people on my
path and that's why I like the classroom
project I thought a lot about your your
comment about its it's not intuitive and
what I think is I think it is intuitive
but it's been taught out there is such
an imbalance in early education and high
school education that it's almost like
those
extreme fundamentalist schools in in the
Islam Islamic world where they grab kids
when their - and the kids are
unavailable by the time they're seven
they're gone if the education system
were more balanced and especially high
school education the intuitiveness would
come out and there'll be a young
generation and generations to follow of
libertarians well I'm sure it's true in
some cases of the education system where
different things would be better but I
disagree with you I don't think most
most classrooms are people are being
indoctrinated against capitalism most of
the time you're just trying to teach
math or telling the kids to be quiet
there's some bias in there but it is
intuitive if you think that for
thousands of years we grew up in little
tribes where you did go to the central
planners for decisions to the tribal
elders who told you when to harvest the
berries then you grow up in a family
where mommy and daddy make the decisions
and you get into a world with a six
seven billion people an international
trade and Adam Smith's invisible hand is
not intuitive it's just intuitive if out
short jobs are going to Asia that
somehow we're losing something
it's intuitive to think that if Bill
Gates makes fifty billion we have 50
billion less it takes some economic
understanding to understand growing of
the pie and that's why we need reason
can you delight us and entertain us with
a couple of anecdotes about some of the
personal liberalism that you faced at
ABC that would shock and inspire us all
well one example is it would surprise me
what stories I had trouble with they
didn't want a reporter to have a point
of view but a drug legalization show
breezed through but a short give me a
break segment on rent control
was endless and it turned out the head
lawyer lived in a rent-controlled
apartment I mean and you know this is
not controversial among you or
economists but they just could not
believe that rent control would hurt
poor people anyways just beyond the pale
another was I don't know Christie help
there was something there was so many
crazy times where well all the media is
afraid of being sued by the trial
lawyers so that was not a particularly
liberal time I'll leave it at that one
they just they just don't get baby and
they think they're not leftist they see
they're steep like tea bags in their
environment which is the New York Times
and NPR I mean I had and the bias is
pervasive
I ain't my books the first two were
bestsellers for one was 13 weeks it got
the number three the other was 11 weeks
have got the number five I never got on
NPR I got in Fox which was a competitor
at the time twenty times and yet NPR
does all these book shows and they say
they're not biased but they just oh he's
icky
he's libertarian in general libertarians
do not use language well for
communicating and whether they're also
whether without sacrificing principle
both that could be done better and more
expression of concern about people would
be that would be tactically very good to
explicitly say you know I want to do
this because it
you're absolutely right and this
tortures us as we try to do TV
programming that so many libertarians
speak like Louise spoke yesterday in
this financial talk that appeals to you
educated people but doesn't reach people
the way Bill Clinton did or Obama does
and I mean you heard it for some of the
professionals today Kennedy when she
does her imitations of people and sort
of falls into the act you really start
to get it that like picks you up and and
it's just real
but that's so different from talking
about pensions I mean the word pension
just makes people go to sleep just
unfunded liability just makes most
people go to sleep I mean Mary O'Grady
last night you could hear her anger that
South America and Central America were
so screwing themselves up and that this
equality worship and you know through
her years of doing this she's
comfortable enough to let that passion
come out in her voice and that's what I
wish more of us had I mean I look I'm a
shy introvert I had to learn how to do
this for television if I couldn't learn
you can learn it too
I've watched you on TV for last 20 years
you haven't at all how did he do it
well I'm thankful for those genes but I
have to say it really sucked when I was
15 and looked 9 and everybody beat me up
but it's great now